the ever deadpan ory Plaza might be on
course to stir up some trouble in Agatha
hna's darkhold Diaries but she's no
stranger to the Marvel Universe in fact
she almost teamed up with the MK with a
mouth himself back in 2017 ory Plaza
caused chaos in the Effect series Legion
as Lenny Busker and the Shadow King Amal
Farooq and was a force to be reckoned
with around the same time there was
another corner of the comic book world
she had an eye on but unfortunately
didn't get the chance to play around in
it involved in the screen with none
other than Wade Wilson in his swey
sequel Deadpool
2 time to make the chimmy chunks as
revealed in an interview with
Cosmopolitan plazer attempted to take on
the role of domino the ludicrously lucky
assassin and ex- Force member who ended
up being played by zazi beats there's a
lot of roles that I really wanted that I
didn't get the one that sticks out to me
for some reason is I think it was
Deadpool 2 I think I was shooting Legion
at the time have things gone to plan it
would have been Plaza's second stint in
the world of mutants after the TV show
which focuses on Charles Xavier son
Plaza admitted she wasn't in the right
Zone at the right time for the potential
gig on paper it certainly seems like
Plaza would have been a great choice for
the dep pan exforce member who always
has luck on her side luck isn't a
superpower yes it is no it isn't yes it
is no man Mario Noz yeah if only the
mutant special gift could have bled into
Plaza's audition because as she saw it
she wasn't in the headp space for it she
admitted I was really not like in a good
Zone cuz auditioning you have to be in
an auditioning Zone and I was in a work
Zone that one hurt me and Ryan Reynolds
like what could go wrong we'd be so
great together of course zazzy beats
provided a brilliant turn as the mutant
that dodged all manner of dangerous fats
and while there's no confirmation if
she'll reprise her role for Deadpool 3
she certainly left her Mark in the
franchise perhaps things worked out for
the best given that Plaza will be
playing tricks and doing all kinds of
magic opposite Katherine Han who will be
returning as Agatha hnes Plaza is
rumored to be stepping in as Rio Vidal
an original character who was allegedly
a green witch and Agatha's former lover
guess she got lucky after all then the
name's Agatha Harkness lovely to finally
meet you dear ory Plaza is confident
that she and Ryan Reynolds would have
made a great team in Deadpool 2 and they
probably would have as they're both
excellent comedic actors while that
opportunity never came to fruition the
pair will finally get the chance to work
together in the upcoming road trip
comedy animal friends which also Stars
Jason Mamoa and Vince Van plot details
for the pizza ateno directed movie are
unknown at this time but the film will
be irrated so perhaps Plaza and Reynolds
will get to engage in the foul mouth
humor that's made the Deadpool franchise
so popular much more with Plaza and
Reynolds both set to Grace a Marvel
Cinematic Universe in the near future
they could cross paths again as they'll
technically be part of the same
franchise until then fans can also look
forward to seeing Plaza in movies such
as megalopolis aad dreaming and other
projects